what we're saying in the world of retail
is a very rapidly changing environment
where customers have more choice than
ever
and they're exercising that choice in
some cases choosing to shop in discount
stores or in convenient shops but of
course increasingly with the rise of
online so more choice but also
significant structural changes driven by
online technology and we think by
bringing these two companies together we
can actually significantly enhance both
businesses sharpen both brands both
propositions by lowering prices
improving ranges adding more quality and
introducing more flexible ways of
shopping as well as making sure that we
create a strong business that employs
three hundred and thirty thousand people
and protects the interests of the
current pension holders so we think it's
a it's a good deal all round
I mean Sainsbury's has been ticking over
quite nicely on its own why do you need
to do this deal is it a defensive move
well both businesses are doing pretty
well at the moment but we think by
bringing the two businesses together we
can create an even stronger business
that can create ways of being able to
invest in customers for the future
clearly we would expect to deliver
buying synergies reduce reduce buying
prices which means we'll be able to pass
those lower prices on to our customers
through focusing price investments on
everyday items so we're looking to
arraigning to reduce prices of everyday
items by around 10% but also things like
range and quality both businesses can
learn from each other and both
businesses are also investing a lot of
money in technology so how customs may
shop with us in the future how confident
are you that you're going to get this
deal past the competition and Markets
Authority well we've obviously done a
lot of work on how this will play out
and we're confident that we'll be able
to put a very strong case to the CMA to
the competition authorities now that's
because in the end they're there to act
on behalf of customers and it's
important that we make that case and say
why is this a good deal for customers
and as I've already said that's because
we look to lower prices improve ranges
improve quality and indeed and provide a
better environment for our colleagues to
work in but you'll have a combined share
of the grocery market of more than 30% I
mean that's more than Tesco ever had at
it
surely the CMA will have some some
conditions that they will want to apply
here well the first point to make is
that the grocery market is actually
bigger than some of the numbers that are
quoted so if you take it as a share of
the total market including other players
like boots and Marks and Spencers which
aren't included then the numbers that
you're talking about actually the
combined share will be around 25 26
percent which is about the same as Tesco
half today but as I say we think by
bringing the businesses together we will
generate significant benefits which we
can ultimately pass back to our
customers and we'll engage with the CMA
how many stores do you think the CMA
will require to dispose of what the CMA
I'm sure we'll recognize is that world
of retail is changing and changing very
rapidly and the nature of competition is
changing so it's not just about large
out-of-town super stores anymore whether
it's discounters whether it's
convenience stores or whether it's the
rise of online all of these things are
different competitive forces which have
amplified significantly over the last
four or five years so I'm sure that the
CMA will be looking at the case in the
round and taking those factors into
account as well now what would your
message for suppliers be surprised
you've already said today in year one of
the the merger you would look to cut
something like 350 million pounds from
the amount that you pay your supplies
that's going to result in a lot of pain
for other people isn't it well our
supplies will benefit from scale and
they'll benefit from the efficiencies of
dealing with one organization rather
than two and we would look to cooperate
with our suppliers through their supply
chains to enable us to deliver those
benefits I don't think some reasonable
for us to say to our suppliers if a
store or Sainsbury's is buying the same
item for a lower price why we wouldn't
be buying for the same price within the
organization and that's the only
assumption that we've made in our
underlying synergy case and ultimately
as I say we'd see those buying prices
being passed to our customers in the
form of lower prices